[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and in
this box is one of the least anticipated
new apple products in a long time it was
announced back in june of 2017 and it's
been a couple months it got delayed now
it's february of the next year 2018 and
it's finally shipping and it's in our
hands it's the homepod
and now that it's here let's see what
it's all about
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so this is apple's entry into the sort
of a newish smart speaker market it's
pretty late obviously but this is what
they've come up with it's a 350 dollar
tissue box sized mesh
cylinder that actually has some really
excellent hardware so setting it up is
pretty simple it has that w1 chip inside
so you just get your iphone somewhere
near it and it shows up on your screen
you name what room it's in and then you
set it up in about a minute like the
airpods did so that's definitely the
apple advantage for easy pairing and
setup of an accessory the weird thing is
it didn't add it to my imac or other
computers as a speaker i kind of wish i
could have tried to use the homepod as a
speaker for my imac but you can't oh
well classic apple but the hardware is
clean and super apolly especially this
white one it's just this fabric bulb
that sits in your living room or on a
table or wherever you decide to put it
little screen up in the circle at the
top and all that has is your volume
controls and a little siri indicator
that lights up when you're using it the
cable as you've probably seen is
built-in it's technically removable with
like a lot of effort so it's pretty
clear apple doesn't want you doing that
that's more for like a technician
working on it after the fact but most
other speakers have removable cables so
that's kind of interesting this one is a
high quality sleeved cable though so i'm
not mad and if you ever pick up and hold
a home pod because of the 3d fabric it's
kind of squishy
just a little i don't know why you'd
ever pick up a speaker but that's true
the one weird thing though with this
hardware is it kind of has this seam on
it it's not easy to see but you can kind
of make it out it's on a different place
on my two different home pods so i
honestly have no idea why it's there you
would think they would always put that
seam on the back by the cord instead of
on the side maybe i'm just being picky i
don't know i've seen some tear downs but
i'm sure jrrig everything will have an
answer for us soon enough on why that
seam is there but once it's set up
there's a lot of talk about the things
homepod can do versus what it can't do
it's supposed to be a smart speaker and
i say it's supposed to be and i put it
in air quotes because there's a lot of
things that when you compare it to
google home or amazon alexa it just
doesn't do but the things it does do it
does really well and really quickly so
the inside of the homepod is a little
different it's seven tweeters all facing
out from the middle and one woofer at
the top firing upwards so in theory it's
creating this sort of a 360 degree sound
that you can hear the same from any
direction around the homepod and then it
also does this bit of analysis using six
built-in microphones to figure out how
close it is to things around like a wall
or an open space it analyzes that space
and then it adjusts the levels to sound
best from every angle no matter where
you are so it's kind of like this smart
sound analysis mostly to not overwhelm
you with bass but the homepod isn't
overly bass heavy in the first place
it's super balanced it does great
instrument separation and honestly it
overall sounds excellent especially for
the size it's only a little bigger than
a normal google home which i think a lot
of people forget about it's really small
but it gets really loud i've listened to
a lot of different music on these
different smart speakers lately and this
is in fact the best sounding one some
people have debated about it versus
google home max the whole max gets
louder for sure at 100 volume it's
almost too loud but it also distorts a
lot at that volume and the bass is
overwhelming so you pretty much have to
go outside to enjoy it that loud homepod
does not get as loud but at 100 volume
it sounds really really good and again
it's unique being that sort of a
circular 360 degree sound most people
put a speaker that's pretty directional
near a wall or a corner anyway but you
kind of get an extra bit of confidence
if you can put this on a table or
anywhere in a room and it'll sound just
as good hey siri play alta
sure here's a personalized station of
valta
so the array of microphones listening
for your voice is excellent it can hear
you pretty much all the time from across
the room when music is playing loud it's
been great at that but again what it
comes down to is what homepod can do and
what homepod can't do it can play music
through apple music so you can ask siri
to play a song or a playlist or play the
radio and if you're an apple music
subscriber it's hooked up to your iphone
and it'll work but let's say you're one
of the 70 million people who uses
spotify and not apple music yes
technically it can work
kinda you can airplay from spotify to a
homepod but then your voice controls
don't work as well you can't ask for a
certain song or a certain playlist you
can go forward and backwards in your
track list but that's about it it's not
ideal but from there homepod can do
pretty much anything siri does so if you
want to ask it questions like who is
this person how tall is this person some
weather trivia some spelling your
classic things like that it can handle
that you can also set reminders so if
you ask it to take out the garbage at
three o'clock it'll do that it'll set a
reminder and your reminders app on your
iphone hey siri who's james harden
james harden currently plays shooting
guard for the rockets
hey siri how tall is he
james harden is six feet five inches
tall
hey siri what's the weather in
honolulu tomorrow
the forecast is calling for
thunderstorms in honolulu hawaii
tomorrow the high will be 78 degrees and
the low will be 66. it can also read
your last text message out loud or send
a text um and we'll get to that in a
second but it also can turn on and off
home kit enabled lights
it can connect to evernote
that's about it but here's what it can't
do so for all the great microphones that
are in home pod i can hear my voice from
across the room it can't distinguish my
voice from your voice so if you have a
home pod and you've been watching this
video i've probably triggered yours
multiple times because it thinks we're
all one voice so that means anyone who's
in the room with you and your homepod
can ask it to read your texts out loud
or send a text message for you
because it thinks it's you so if you're
not into that you definitely want to
uncheck the show personal info tab
either during the setup or after the
setup you can change it but that's just
a weird quirk about homepod you would
think with mike's so good and with
apple's software so good it should be
able to tell our voices apart homepod
also cannot ever connect to anything
that's not an iphone it can't be used as
a bluetooth speaker and there's no audio
jack so you can't plug anything in to
use its audio quality for anything other
than an iphone you also cannot set
spotify as your default music player
anytime you ask it to play something via
your voice it will have to be apple
music you cannot connect two of them
together as a stereo pair yet that's
apparently i've heard coming in a
software update but as of right now you
can connect two google home maxes
together as a stereo pair doesn't happen
with homepod yet you can't order
products online you can't order food
online you can't call an uber or a lift
with it you can't have it read calendar
events or set any calendar events you
can't set multiple timers at the same
time only one at a time which seems like
something you would do in a kitchen with
a smart speaker you can't have it make
phone calls by your voice again that's
something you have to set up on your
phone and then airplay to the homepod
you can't look up a recipe you can't use
find my phone the list goes on and on
there's so many things that homepod when
you compare it to other smart speakers
just doesn't do so in conclusion homepod
is a weird product it's 349 bucks right
now which means you can compare it to
other smart speakers like google home or
amazon alexa or some other dedicated
speaker systems like sonos it sounds
better than any other bluetooth speaker
it sounds better than the other smart
speakers and honestly it sounds better
than a lot of the dedicated sound
systems like a sonos the audio
engineering that went into this thing
the clarity the instrument separation
the bass response the 360 degree sound
is next level the engineers should be
proud of this but in terms of smartness
smartness siri versus alexa or google
home
not even close so you've probably heard
this conclusion before but if you're in
the apple ecosystem meaning you use an
iphone you use siri a lot and you're an
apple music subscriber then this is the
best sounding smart speaker that you can
get but in most cases honestly you're
going to be better off buying a much
smarter speaker that can do way more
that sounds almost as good it really
feels like getting a homepod right now
and using it a lot just magnifies
everything that's wrong with siri and
all siri's shortcomings so the
engineering team that made it sound so
good they should totally make a separate
350
apple speaker with a headphone jack that
anyone can connect to and that would do
well in its own competitive world but
for now if you're in the market for a
smart speaker
i'd say shop around watch some other
reviews
this isn't the first choice
until then thanks for watching talk to
you guys the next one peace